teeth for crisis right now
and this nation needs presidential
leadership right now
presidential leadership is willing to
model the steps we
should be taking for our to save our own
lives and lives of our families
you know we can wish this away but we
have to face it
head on we have to take it head on
using every power available to me as
president
we'll have a national coordinated
strategy that will that will beat this
virus
you know and as tough as things are now
i firmly believe better days are ahead
we've got some good news yesterday
the fda committed a committee i should
say recommended
emergency use authorization for pfizer's
bio and tech cova 19 vaccine
but we're grateful for the scientists at
these not only there but other
great organizations researchers who
developed this vaccine
and several others on the way and we're
just as grateful to the scientists and
the public experts
who evaluated its safety and efficiency
free
from political influence i want to make
it clear to the public
you should have confidence in this there
is no political influence these are
first-rate scientists taking their time
looking at all of the elements
that need to be looked at scientific
integrity led us to this point
we know the immense challenges and hard
work ahead
earlier this week i announced our covert
response team
that will scale up the manufacturing
distribution and injection
of the vaccine we set a bold and doable
challenge in my first 100 days
100 million shots in 100 days
asking the american people to wear masks
for
the first 100 days of our administration
if we get the necessary funding from
congress
we can get most of our schools open in
100 days but we need the help from the
congress and the funding
the first 100 days won't end to cope at
19 but meeting those goals
can slow the spread save lives and get
us back to our lives
with the people we love the most and
we'll also be getting the right people
confirmed
during this period of time and in place
to manage this robust aggressive plan to
contain the virus
help us build back better than ever and
make sure everyone is included
now today i'm really pleased to add
members
to my team that'll get the job done in
addition to the pandemics grim milestone
the economic crisis has left
millions of americans out of work
without a paycheck
without health insurance unable to put
enough food on the table literally
unable to put food in the table
and unsure whether they can pay their
rent for the new when the new year
begins
or make their mortgage payments it's
affecting everyone from farmers to
students
seniors to veterans in red states blue
states small towns and big cities
that's why the congress needs to act and
act now
on the covet package i spoke to my two
friends who are still in the congress
the vice president and the soon-to-be
secretary of hud
we have to get this done they're pushing
hard
but it doesn't look so good right now
but it has to get done before they go
home
millions and millions of americans
simply can't wait any longer
we shouldn't we can't get bogged down on
issues that don't help people
state and local governments need the
help not only that
as i've said for months we need to
protect essential personnel
like law enforcement firefighters to
make sure everything is in place
and effectively distribute the vaccine
so that we can do that
this relief package won't be the total
answer even if it gets passed
but it's an important first step there's
so much we have to do
these crises have ripped the blinders
right off the systemic racism that
exists in america the american people
now can see clearly black latino native
americans nearly three times more likely
to die from covet
and more likely to get get covert to
begin with
black and team black and latino
unemployment rates too hot too large too
high
communities of color are left to ask
whether they'll ever be able to break
the cycle
we're in good times they lie in bad
times
they're hit first and the hardest and in
recovery
they take the longest to bounce back
vice president-elect harris
and i knew we'd have our work cut out
for us when we got elected
but we also knew we could build a team
that would meet this unique and
challenging moment in american history
some are familiar faces some are new in
their roles
all are facing new circumstances and
challenges
that's a good thing they bring deep
experience
and bold new thinking above all they
know how government
should and can work for all americans
for secretary of agriculture i nominate
tom vilsack
an outstanding two-term governor of iowa
the best secretary of agriculture i
believe this country's ever had
he was there when the great recession
was pummeling
rural america over eight years he
oversaw a record-breaking investment to
bring us back
he implemented the recovery act to help
rural communities recover and rebuild
tom helped expand markets around the
world for american farmers he improved
our food
safety standards and helped millions of
children and families receive healthy
meals
he wasn't anxious to come back he wasn't
looking for this job
but i was persistent
and uh i asked him to serve again in
this role because he knows the usda
inside and out he knows the government
inside now
we need that experience now
one in six americans and a quarter
a quarter of the children in america are
facing
hungary the opioid crisis in rural
america is a rural america crisis
as is the climate crisis with droughts
floods wiping out crops in small towns
farmers and small businesses small towns
rural communities
white black latino are reeling from the
pandemic and economic downturn
tom knows the full range of resources
available to this department
to get immediate relief to those most in
need and address the crises
not one the crises facing rural america
he knows how to build back better for
all americans
he helped develop my rural plan for
america in the campaign
and he now has the dubious distinction
of having it carried out
it's a good plan that includes making
american agriculture the first in the
world to achieve
net zero emissions and create new
sources of income for farmers in the
process
by paying farmers to put their land in
conservation
plant cover crops that use the soil to
capture carbon
and it'll ensure that usda promotes true
racial equality and inclusion he
recognizes the history of discrimination
and will root it out wherever it exists
i've known tom for a long time and i'm
confident he'll get it done
for secretary of housing and urban
envelope i am i'm
really pleased to nominate congressman
marcia fudge
well i might add could do many jobs
beyond the one i'm asking you to do
but i think the job i'm asking you to do
congresswoman is critically important to
everything
that the vice president and i believe is
how we're going to build back better
as a former mayor she understands how to
manage challenges and
forge solutions at a local level
for 12 years in congress she's
represented the great city of cleveland
you know uh though i think of her most
significant political feat was being
elected president of deltas
i know from this state how powerful the
deltas are
you think i'm kidding i'm not
she developed an entire career for
fighting for working people on issues
from affordable housing
to urban revitalization during the great
recession
her district was hit hard by the housing
crisis
she spent the past decade working to
improve blighted neighborhoods
create safer more affordable communities
she also understands where you live
impacts on your health
access to education jobs and economic
opportunity
zip code should not determine the
outcomes on all those issues
she's going to bring that same vision
touch secretary using
every lever at her disposal to help the
millions of americans
facing evictions trying to pay for their
mortgages
find their way through this crisis
and i think you'll see that she's going
to lead our charge to make housing more
affordable
and accessible should work to increase
home ownership
as a means towards wealth generation
particularly for communities of culture
culture communities of color it's not
just
dealing with the other issues we have to
be able to build
wealth in communities of color
and she's also going to help us build
back better by working across the
ideological spectrum
to fulfill the promise of hud's mission
and here's what its mission is it's
often forgotten
to create strong sustainable inclusive
communities
and quality affordable homes for all
end of quote marshall be the first woman
to lead hood in more than 40 years
and just the second black woman ever i'm
honored to have her serve and thank her
for being
willing to do it in the biden-harris
administration
at this critical moment in our nation's
history
and for secretary of veterans affairs i
nominate dennis mcdonough
former white house chief of staff deputy
national security advisor
deep experience on capitol hill i've
known dennis for a long time
he shares my belief that we have many
obligations as a nation
we have only one truly sacred obligation
to prepare and equip our troops that we
send into harm's way
and then to care for them and their
families when they return
he regularly traveled as i did to iraq
and afghanistan
to meet directly with our service
members to see what they were going
through
understand the strain and the impact on
them and their families
he'd visit them as i did often at walter
reed to see
firsthand the visible and invisible
wounds
they brought home he knows the cost of
war on veterans and their families
from the toll on their physical and
mental health to the access to good
paying jobs
and he's a fierce advocate and a
relentless workhorse
and i believe and i think everyone who's
ever worked on those he's a world-class
manager
with an innate understanding for how
government can
and must work for our veterans
he worked closely with our then va
secretary bob mcdonnell
and with the congress to increase va
funding to ensure veterans to get the
benefits they earned and they deserve
and by the way
he knows we have a very very steep hill
to climb in getting
more funding more docs more
psychiatric nurses more folks out of the
private
sector into into the va
that includes implementing veterans
choice
a bill led by my friend bernie sanders
and my late friend
american hero john mccain and signed
into law by president obama in 2014 to
help veterans
access quality health care that they
need when they need it
and in this role i've given dennis a
clear mission
fight like hell fight like hell for our
veterans and their families
and anyone anyone who's worked with
dennis will tell you
he'll move heaven and earth to fix any
problem to get a job done
he'll also work closely with our
secretary of designated
uh secretary of defense designate lloyd
austin and the entire cabinet
as and jill as first lady to pull every
leader
every lever to help us build back the va
better than ever
and dennis yeah it's a family endeavor
his wife kari leads a non-profit that
helps connect veterans and military
families
in local with local communities so they
can help each other
out and build a stronger country
together
we're both uh both our spouses
feel incredibly strongly about this and
have for some time
all the veterans and military families
nominating a va secretary is one of the
most important decisions
i believe a president can make and
dennis will always be there for you i
promise you
always fighting for it as will the vice
president and i
for the united states trade
representative who nominated catherine
ty
a trusted trade expert a dedicated
public servant who knows government
and who spent her career leveling the
playing field for american workers and
their families
that's not hyperbole that's a fact she's
currently serves as a chief lawyer on
trade for the powerful house ways and
means committee
sharing praise from both lawmakers and
both political parties and from both
labor
and business as well now that's a feat
across the board but all kids aside you
have i've got more calls
complimenting me on your appointment
than you can imagine
during the obama bite administration she
was the chief trade enforcer against
unfair trade practices by
china which will be a key priority in
the biden harris administration
she understands that we need a more
strategic
to beast considerably more strategic
than we've been
and how we trade and that makes us all
stronger how we're made stronger by
trade
one that leaves nobody behind she can
work closely with my economic and
national security and foreign policy
teams trade will be a critical pillar in
our ability to build back better
and carry out our foreign policy foreign
policy for the middle class when i
announced my candidacy i talked about a
foreign policy for the middle class
and i meant that in a literal sense she
also brings a sophisticated
understanding of the threats of climate
change to trade
as well as addresses the climate crisis
with
urgency she also embodies a
a powerful immigration story of america
her parents were both born in china
they moved to taiwan and then came to
the united states where catherine was
born
her parents became government scientists
at walter reed and nih
inspiring their daughter to pursue a
career in public service
catherine says she's the first american
board member
born member of a family and a second
generation u.s government servant
that's a great way of expressing it if
confirmed
she'd be the first asian american the
first woman of color to serve in this
position
in our nation our economy our workers
our businesses
we're fortunate to have her serve in
this role
as director of the white house domestic
policy council
i spent some time convincing this
wonderful
public servant but we i'm appointing
susan rice former united states
ambassador to the united nations
former national security adviser to
president obama
former cabinet member team player policy
heavyweight through
tough negotiator trusted and tested
public servant
who i've known for a long time not only
admired but become
friends with she'll lead
and coordinate my critical domestic
policy agenda
and she's going to elevate and
turbocharge a revitalized domestic
policy council to help us build back
better on
every issue across the board should work
closely with my director
national economic council brian dees
should work closely with my national
security advisor jake sullivan
and the national security council
together they'll align domestic policy
economic policy and national security
unlike ever before this is a big and
critical role
that's why i asked susan to serve she's
been there
she knows what it takes like she did and
helped me mobilize the entire federal
government to end the ebola crisis
and her voice is particularly needed at
this critical moment
the granddaughter of immigrants
descendant of enslaved people
susan will be an effective and tireless
champion
for all americans and she knows i'm
really thrilled
she was willing to come back be at my
side in the white house
to each of you on this team
you have my gratitude and gratitude to
the vice president of me for answering
the call to serve again
to your families thank you we know the
sacrifice
you're making to allow your family
member to serve as they are going to
god willing and to career civil servants
at these agencies we look forward to
working with you
because we know how many talented people
are there
it's time to rededicate ourselves to the
mission
our government agencies were entrusted
with
and to the american people help
is on the way i promise we're not going
to let you down
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops now i'm going to turn this
over to the team
starting with our next secretary of
agriculture tom vilsack
tom thank you podiums earth i guess
they're going to clean it up
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm honored by the trust that you've
placed in me to return to the vital work
of the usda at a very critical moment
for so many families and communities
throughout america
and to begin that work by embracing the
full benefits
of a diverse and inclusive senior
leadership team
in the department as i was proud to do
in my previous tenure and to continue
the important work
of rooting out inequities and systemic
racism
in the systems we govern and the
programs we lead
when abraham lincoln established the
department of agriculture
he called it the people's department
i look forward to making good on that
moniker
for all people as we build back
better i happen to be celebrating a
birthday on sunday
one of those round numbers that causes
you to reflect on your life
thinking back on the path of my life
where it began in an orphanage in
pittsburgh pennsylvania
to iowa where my incredible wife christy
and i raised our family
and the home we've made there to
standing here
today being given a chance to serve
our country once again
i feel enormously lucky and grateful
to live in a country for my paths like
mine
are possible a country as the
president-elect often says
is defined by possibilities
but unfortunately and tragically not all
have experienced those possibilities so
i consider it my duty
and my responsibility to help expand
those possibilities for all
americans at the usda
i know firsthand the character of the
dedicated public servants
who work hard each and every day to
fulfill the mission
of that department and i'm especially
grateful
for the chance to get back to work
alongside them
one of our first charges will need to be
to contribute
all we can as a department to aid in the
dynamic response
reviving rural communities and economies
addressing dire food shortages and
getting workers
and producers the relief they need to
hang on
and to come back stronger
when we emerge from this crisis we're
going to have an incredible opportunity
before
us to position american agriculture to
lead our nation and the world
in combating climate change and reaping
the
new good paying jobs and farm income
that will come
from that leadership to make landmark
investments in communities
throughout rural america especially
those mired in poverty
for far too long by adopting the 10
20 30 rule of congressman jim kleiber
that sets aside 10 percent of federal
funding to communities
where 20 percent of people have been
caught beneath
the poverty line for 30 years or more
and to ensure that every child in our
country
and all those who are in need have
access to safe
affordable and nutritious food
we need to build back a vibrant and
resilient rural economy
that creates new possibilities for
manufacturing workers
for family forest owners for farmers
ranchers and producers
that helps to make life better and
richer for them
and safer for all of us and under my
watch
the usda will be a team player
working with our sister agencies to
advance issues of shared interest
from rebuilding our infrastructure to
fixing a broken immigration system
to combating and fighting the opioid
crisis
i look forward to pursuing that work on
behalf of the american people
and especially those who live work and
raise their families in rural america
and i will end by expressing my profound
gratitude
to the president-elect and vice
president-elect for
this amazing opportunity to serve thank
you
mr president-elect my good friend
madam vice president-elect to my family
my friends my sorority sisters my
constituents all
i thank you for the opportunity to join
this remarkable team and work on behalf
of people in every city
and community to serve all those who are
struggling
and looking for the fair shot we all
deserve
when i think about the enormity of the
task ahead of us
i am reminded of the book of matthew
where it is written
foxes have holes birds have nests but
the son of man has no place to lay his
head
there is dignity and there is grace
within every woman every man and every
child in this nation
including those who live on the
outskirts of hope
those who work hard but still struggle
to make it work
and those who have no place to lay their
head
it is one of the highest
responsibilities of our government
to see them to see their dignity
and to lift them up i remember the
feeling i had as
a kid of the safety security
and peace of mind contained in one word
home i remember the comfort of knowing
that no matter what happened
i could always go home but far too many
americans live without that feeling
more and more have had that comfort
ripped away
the crisis of a pandemic that has
threatened their lives
the crisis of a recession that has
swallowed up jobs
hours wages and lifelines
the crisis of injustice that forced
community
color to make it in america with one
dream tied behind their back
each crisis chips away at their hope
at the promise of our nation but i
believe that hope is on the way
because i know that president-elect and
vice president-elect are building a team
that is grounded in dignity and our task
at the department of
housing and human development urban
development will be to stand up for the
dignity of all americans
and deliver the promise of our nation to
all those left out in the cold
we will take on the deep set roots of
poverty
and homelessness we will fight for
housing in every community
that is affordable decent and safe
we will help more americans secure the
dream of homeownership
to close the gaps of inequity build
wealth
and pass it on to their children we will
pursue
creative development projects to shape
our landscapes and skylines
restart the engines of cities that have
stalled out
and launch new opportunities in home
towns across
america but perhaps most importantly
of all we will help people believe once
again
that their government cares about them
no matter who they are
that we understand their problems as the
president-elect
often recalls his father's words i am
honored to have this chance
to help restore the people's faith to
deliver for them
and make them proud and to build back
better
alongside this dedicated team i thank
you
for the opportunity to serve
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm deeply humbled by the trust and
confidence you have placed in me
and if confirmed by the senate will be
honored to serve
as the secretary of veterans affairs mr
president-elect you have pledged to
restore the soul of our nation and to
unite us as americans
in this work there is a mission that can
bring every american
together caring for our nation's
veterans
and their families as you have said this
is a sacred
obligation and i know it's a that for
you and dr
biden it's also very deeply personal
i've been inspired by veterans in my
life as well
today i'm thinking of my grandpa
mcdonough a marine
all the troops i met on my visits to
afghanistan and iraq
and the wounded warriors i spent time
with at walter reed
are showing around the white house i'm
thinking of the many vets i've had the
pleasure to serve with
in and out of government who have put
the character and training that they
developed in uniform
to work to continue serving our country
as civilians
i'm also thinking of one of my high
school football coaches back in
stillwater minnesota
in iowa joe sam samuels
he stormed the beaches of normandy and
in home hospice at the end of his life
he and his family were grateful for the
compassion
of the va when he passed
his wife gave me his coaching jacket one
of my most most
prized possessions coach sam's jacket
reminds me why we're here
our men and women in uniform have had
our country's back
and when they come home we need to have
their back
as the president-elect has said his
marching marching order to me
is very clear fight like hell for our
veterans
we're going to fight like hell to give
our veterans and their families the
health care
respect and dignity they deserve
that means helping our veterans build
civilian lives of meaning and
opportunity
making our va even more welcoming to all
veterans including our women veterans
veterans of color and lgbtq veterans
and keeping faith with our incredible
military families and caregivers
because we need to have their backs too
to the men and women of the va many of
you veterans
yourselves you work tirelessly to
take care of our veterans and your
demanding jobs have been made
even more difficult by the pandemic
to you and to the many dedicated vets
service organizations
who include vets survivors and their
families
i look forward to being your partner
one united team and delivering care and
support
that's second to none finally
taking care of of our veterans is not a
job for the va alone
every federal department and agency has
a role to play
and i will fight like hell to make that
happen and even though
only one percent of americans wear the
uniform
under president biden every american
will be
called upon to embrace our
responsibility to support our veterans
and our military families mr
president-elect
madam vice president-elect on behalf of
my wife kari and our family
thank you for this opportunity to serve
may god bless our troops
our veterans and their families and as a
nation
may we always give them our very best
just as they have done for us thanks
very much
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm grateful for this opportunity to
serve and look forward to working with
you
with our partners across the
administration and with the bright
and dedicated public servants at ustr to
deliver
for the american people when the
president-elect approached me
about taking on this role two memories
from my past spring to mind
the first was from when i initially
joined ustr in 2007
i was filling out paperwork and
providing information about my family
history
my parents were born in mainland china
and grew up
in taiwan in the 1960s president
kennedy's immigration reforms
welcomed them to america as graduate
students
in the sciences my dad would become
a researcher at walter reed helping the
army
advance treatments for afflictions that
debilitated american gis
fighting in the vietnam war my mom still
works at the national institutes of
health
developing treatments for opioid
addiction
they were naturalized in 1979 five years
after i was born in connecticut
and it wasn't until decades later
filling out that paperwork
that it occurred to me that i became an
american
before my parents the very first
american
in our family
the second memory that came to mind was
from several years later
when a colleague and i from ustr went to
geneva
to present a case suing china before the
world trade organization
we sat down at the table she whose
parents had emigrated from south india
and i whose parents had come from taiwan
and my heart swelled with pride as we
raised our placard
and stated that we were there to present
the case
on behalf of the united states of
america
two daughters of immigrants there to
serve
to fight for and to reflect the nation
that had opened doors of hope and
opportunity
to our families those memories fill me
with gratitude
for being an american and for what
america is
at our best and they remind me of the
extraordinary responsibilities
that come with the honor as we navigate
our relationships with the world
trade is like any other tool in our
domestic or foreign policy
it is not an end in itself it is a means
to create more hope and opportunity
for people and it only succeeds
when the humanity and dignity of every
american
and of all people lie at the heart of
our approach
i am proud to join with leaders who
instill their policy with purpose
and dignity the opportunity and hope
that make trade a force for good in our
nation
and the world i am very proud
to be an advocate for american workers
to stand up
for their ingenuity and their innovation
and for america's interests across the
globe
i look forward to harnessing the power
of our trade relationships
to help communities lift themselves out
of the current crisis
and i am grateful for this chance to
serve fight for
and reflect america on behalf of all of
our people
once again thank you
thank you so much mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i'm honored
to join this tremendous team today we
confront
a profoundly connected set of crises
a relentless pandemic a struggling
economy
urgent demands for racial equity and
justice
a climate in need of healing a democracy
in need of repair and a world
in need of renewed american leadership
in the 21st century
our foreign economic and domestic
imperatives
are deeply intertwined
tackling these challenges is personal to
me
i'm a descendant of immigrants and the
enslaved
and service is in our blood
my paternal great grandfather was born a
slave
in south carolina and joined the union
army
he went on to get a college degree
become an ame minister
and he founded the bordentown school in
new jersey
which for seven decades provided african
americans with vocational
and college preparatory educations
two generations later my father emmett
rice
served as a tuskegee airman and as a
governor
of the federal reserve my maternal
grandparents came to this country
from jamaica with no education
but working for decades as a janitor and
a maid
they saved and they scraped to send all
five of their children to college
and on to professional success my mother
lois rice was known as the mother of the
pell grant program
which has enabled 80 million americans
to reach college
and is she like to say not bad
for a poor colored girl from portland
maine
but today for far too many
the american dream has become an empty
promise
a cruel mockery of lives held back
by barriers new and old
that is not good enough for any
american but we know that throughout our
history
americans have forged opportunity out of
crisis
after the civil war we ended slavery and
enshrined the concept
of equal protection under the law
during the great depression we
established the works progress
administration
and civilian conservation corps after
world war
ii we enacted the gi bill
in the 1960s we abolished legal
segregation
established full voting rights and
enacted medicare
and medicaid now at the foot
of yet another bridge between crisis
and opportunity i'm honored and excited
to take on this role joe biden and
kamala harris's vision
for our future is expansive
but achievable america must finally
become
a nation where every child
from akron to arkansas from the bronx
to brownsville from the sioux nation to
south central los angeles
can dream without limits and make
her dreams come true i have no illusions
about the difficulty of making that
vision real
but we are here to get hard stuff done
our top priorities will be to help end
the pandemic
and revitalize the economy so that it
delivers
for all to bring dignity and humanity
to our broken immigration system to
advance racial equity justice
and civil rights for all to ensure that
health care is accessible and affordable
and to educate and train americans to
compete
and thrive in the 21st century
i profoundly believe that we all
rise or fall together absolutely
all of us so mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i promise you
i will do everything i can to help this
country i love
to build back better to make our
government deliver
for all americans and for working
families
and to bring the american dream far
closer
to reality for all
thank you very much
good afternoon over these past few
days and weeks we have announced members
of our administration
who will help us meet the unprecedented
challenges
facing the american people we have
brought together
a health care team that will help
contain this pandemic once and for all
an economic team that will help build an
economy that works
for working people and all those looking
to work and a national security and
foreign policy team
that will help keep our nation safe
and restore and advance our leadership
around the world today we are announcing
leaders
who will help deliver immediate relief
to every corner of our great country
from rural communities
to big cities and every place in between
leaders who will help care for our
veterans and
their families an advance opportunity
for all americans at this consequential
moment
in our country at a time when one in
eight households
say they didn't have enough money for
food in the past week
we need leaders who understand
that no one should go hungry in the
united states of america
at a time when one in six renters are
behind on rent
we need leaders who will not only help
provide relief to all who need it
but help address the affordable housing
crisis in america
you know i was in high school by the
time my mother
saved up enough money to put down a down
payment on a home
and i understand the dignity of
homeownership
and the importance of making the
american dream
a reality for everyone at a time when
veterans
including those i've represented in
california have been strained by almost
two decades of war
and economic hardship we must have
leaders
who will treat all who have worn our
nation's uniform and their families
with the dignity and respect they have
earned
leaders who will be focused on doing
what is in the best
interests of the american people
who will negotiate trade deals that are
good for workers
and good for our economy who will
address
the defining challenges of our time from
combating our climate crisis
to advancing racial justice that
is what these remarkable americans will
do
i know them well and some are very dear
friends
these leaders have different backgrounds
and life's experience
and they bring to their roles different
skills perspectives
and areas of expertise and
they all reflect the very best
of our nation they are all dedicated and
compassionate public servants
and all of them are ready to hit the
ground
running on day one so mr
president-elect congratulations on these
outstanding choices
i look forward to working with each
member of the team
and the whole team that we are bringing
together to meet the urgent challenges
facing our nation
and to rebuild our country in a way that
lifts up
all americans thank you
thank you president-elect biden
how soon do you plan on taking the
coronavirus vaccine
did hunter biden commit a crime
have you spoken to your son mr president
of life
hey